whether you're so partisan starting an
Etsy store a chef opening a food truck
the CEO of an automobile company or a
freelance graphic designer one of the
most critical business decisions you'll
have to make is what price to ask for
your goods or services charge too much
and you'll lose customers but charge too
little and you lose money you might
remember this graph from your high
school economics class it suggests that
as the price of a product increases the
supply the number of people who want to
sell it goes up but the demand the
number of people who want to buy it goes
down supposedly there's a magic number
where these two lines meet that's high
enough to keep seller selling but low
enough to keep buyers buy it it's called
the equilibrium price and it's a useful
theoretical concept but it's not much
help to Ruth here who's about to launch
a line of homemade bath soaps on Etsy
even with a lot of expensive market
research it would be very difficult for
her to predict how much people will be
willing to pay for her lavender
lemongrass facial scrub she can however
calculate her costs in other words how
much time and money she has to spend to
make one bar assuming that her costs
stay the same the more she charges above
that the more her profit margin will
increase but the more her sales will
decrease that is if this graph is an
accurate representation of how customers
behave but this graph doesn't take into
account one crucial fact that humans
aren't robots and our financial behavior
doesn't track neatly along a straight
line just ask louis vuitton if raising
prices always lowers demand
[Music]
in 2007 a group of researchers tried to
get into customers heads literally using
an MRI machine
they found that just looking at prices
activated the areas of the brain
associated with physical pain funnily
enough that response was less when they
took away the dollar even less without
the decimals and least of all when
written out now you know how fancy
restaurants get away with $40 chicken
the painful feeling of losing something
like money is known in economics as
negative utility conversely positive
utility is the satisfaction we get from
gaining or consuming something and that
doesn't necessarily mean a physical
benefit the sense of status one gets
from buying a five thousand dollar
designer handbag is positive utility so
is the peace of mind of having a $20
fire extinguisher under your sink even
if you never use it it's all about
emotion every customer wants to walk
away from every transaction with net
positive utility meaning they want to
feel like they gained more than they
lost but how do customers know whether
something is over or under priced short
answer
they don't really I mean do you know how
much it costs to manufacture a computer
or a candy bar without that information
consumers are forced to guess at a
product's value and they do that through
comparisons in study after study when
presented with multiple brands of
varying price points most consumers tend
to gravitate towards the median price
that is they assume the most expensive
option is probably overpriced but
they're also wary that the cheapest
might be an inferior product so the one
right in the middle is their best
estimation of the products true value
this is sometimes referred to as the
magic of the middle and understanding it
is essential to attracting customers
Sarah is a freelance graphic designer
and she's asked to bid on a job she
really wants but she's relatively new to
the industry and not sure how much she
should quote she asks other
professionals in the field wouldn't they
typically charge and even cold call some
design companies pretending to be a
client not very honest but revealing
and finds out that graphic design rates
in her area run from fifty to a hundred
and fifty dollars per hour Sarah really
wants this job so she might be tempted
to offer a rock-bottom rate of $25 an
hour but too many potential clients that
could be a red flag they might assume
that someone offering substandard prices
will deliver substandard work she
decides to quote just under the median
price $80 an hour and thanks to her
strong portfolio she lands the job in
other words price is often interpreted
as an indicator of quality this should
be very relevant to someone like Ruth
whose customers will only buy her fancy
bath soaps if they believe their fancy
her potential buyers might enjoy saving
money on socks or a toilet paper but
they're not looking to skimp on Mother's
Day gifts how powerful is the effect of
price on psychology one medical study
found that placebos were more effective
if the patients were saving them
believed they cost more the fact is that
it's very difficult to make low prices a
successful business strategy partly
because they are often interpreted as an
indicator of poor quality but it's also
because average profit margins are much
smaller than people assume a survey
found that American consumers believed
the average profit margin in the US to
be 46 percent that is they assumed that
for every dollar a company takes in it
will keep 46 cents in profit the actual
number closer to five percent to
understand how sensitive profit margins
are to pricing take the theoretical
example of Martin who owns and operates
a couple food trucks selling Cuban
sandwiches
Martin sells about 100 sandwiches a day
at 8 bucks a sandwich with a total
yearly revenue of around 300 thousand
dollars after subtracting all of his
food labor and operating costs he's left
with about 45,000 in profits a year for
a respectable profit margin of 15% but
Martin wonders if he could attract more
business by lowering his prices after
all the pizza place next door sells two
slices for seven bucks if he knocked
just 75 cents
sandwich price maybe he could poach some
of their customers he does the math and
is shocked to discover that even at that
modest price decrease his yearly profits
would be slashed to under $20,000
he'd have to sell more than twice as
many sandwiches as he is now just to
break even and how many customers could
he realistically expect to gain from
such a small discount this can be even
more disastrous for an entrepreneur like
Gabe who sells men's razors online if he
offers a steep discount for a limited
time he could indeed see a jump in sales
but those might just be his regular
customers taking advantage of this
little stockpile people who would have
eventually bought the razors anyway at
the regular price this is what happened
at General Motors in 2005 when they
announced an unprecedented price cut in
their cars sales skyrocketed for a
couple months and then plummeted
essentially they were poaching customers
from future quarters they ended up
losing billions if you want to try to
beat the competition with low prices
you'll have to make it a part of your
business plan from the get-go that means
scrupulously keeping costs and wages as
low as possible while constantly
communicating to your customers that
your product is reliable or you couldn't
focus instead on making a great product
and ask a price that you genuinely think
it's worth and be ready to adjust to
feedback from the market and that's our
two cents if you'd like to dig deeper
into the thrilling world of prices you
can check out confessions of the pricing
man by Herman Simon if you've ever sold
anything or started a small business how
did you decide on a price let us know in
the comments
you
[Music]